the humidity has toned down a bit in
atlanta in the past few days while the
power keeps heating up
the back to back division champs out in
front again they are
strong yet they have company in a
surprise contender that comes to town
it's september baseball
like never before so a 2-2-5 era in his
first two go-rounds
the rookie making his third career
outing and then now he'll go up against
starling marty
and he's an aggressive man at the plate
and goes after the second
pitch ncrt is all over it one of the
best out there in center and starling
marte kind of tipping his cat
yeah that's still like fake tip the cap
you're kind of angry
but you got to give a credit where chris
do it's a great play right here but uh
marty has a knock
well for the marlins pitcher that he's
gonna have to be very good on both sides
of the plate that's one thing they
worked on
in the off-season to try to get him to
not be as predictable
i i think just because of the value he
brings on the base pass
he's he's got so much power for his size
and there he goes right now
and he's got second and then off to
third he goes as well
this is his third stolen base of the
year 37 swipes last year
and iranian knows that this man has
owned them
freeman sends it to left center and he's
got himself an rbi
ronald acuna jr can trot home and score
here comes another one
swanson's in there safely it's a two rbi
knock for freeman two nothing atlanta in
the first
such a good hitter such a hits the ball
where's pitch
he's just hits the gaps as well as
anybody in the big leagues
now it's marcakes marquez
up the middle nice backhanded stop and
the marlins turn
two big double play bomb queued up by
jose arena to limit the damage
somebody asked me a long time ago what
would you rather have would rather be
the marlins
see a nice little strike out there
chisholm at second for rojas
ground ball strikeout then he threw one
away that was the error against anderson
and that one connects down the line
that's a fair ball
chisholm will come on down and miguel
rojas has driven in the first run for
miami it's 2-1
good at bat he gets down early with two
strikes battled back to a 3-2 count
and rifle going down in the corner and
this sophomore has locked down the third
base job for atlanta
rips it and a nice stop in short by
miguel rojas
to catch it on the fly for out number
one so now echeverria is on in ciarte
the nine hitter
payoff pitched in ciarte and it's gonna
fall and then get past dickerson and
left
and here comes echeverria rounding third
he's gonna
come home and make it three to one
atlanta
a little chip shot to left field and
dickerson misplays it
and they're gonna review another play at
third hope to go one for two
of the marlins
second strikeout of the inning for ian
anderson
it's now two on for miami
birdie clocks one pass short and he has
himself a base hit
and then comes aguilar he will score
it's 3-2
john bertie with an rbi single now
they're depending on marty to get a two
out hit
runner at third less than two outs
dickerson now just one for five
at converting that base runner from
third on the season
marty down the line that's a fair ball
and that'll bring home the run
rojas ties the game at three off the
marte
extra basic it's a double for the new
guy who keeps coming through
he's followed by aguilar
and he lobs one to left and that's gonna
fall
marty with his plus speed has no problem
scoring it's 4-3
miami has grabbed it that's just a big
league at bat and now good luck with
this guy
ronald acuna jr and there is some
history between these two
and he hit him again
i don't believe this one was intentional
the previous
problems they've had i can't answer that
question but this is part of pitching
he's got a chance to redeem himself and
put the braves either ahead or at least
tie the game and
cuny puts it on the ground they'll make
the play home and
they got him matcha is toast and the
marlins preserve a 4-3 lead
this is it james hoyt summoned in to
face marcelazuna
he was swinging for the seats there
james hoyt
buries the pitch and closes up the
braves threat
in the seventh a pinch hitter in adam
duvall
sends it to center and it's going a long
way
forget about it adam duvall
powers up and ties the game at four
just amazing how this team finds ways
to win games late and darnow over two
with two strikeouts
there it is and it is a ground ball and
the marlins get the perfect double play
ball
to wrap up this nine double in two
singles he drove in a run
back in the second inning
and that is sent to right center and
that
is gonna fall open real estate there for
miguel rojas to bring in a run
the marlins strike anderson will hold up
at
third it's 5-4 miami
and the braves are down to their last
chance
on the ground backhanded by rojas in
that short glove and guess who
the man of the day miguel rojas seals
the deal for the marlins nick vinson
picks up the save